نذهب الان الى فرح الزمان شوقي ربما نتحدث
عن اهم
التصريحات والقرارات التي يتم اتخاذها على
مستوى الجمهوريه التركيه الحديث الان عن
ارسال مدعين عامين الى المناطق المتضرره
الولايات العشر المنكوبه وايضا قبل ذلك
نريد ان نتحدث معك فرح عن اخر التحديثات
القادمه من اداره الكوارث والطوارئ افاد
اليك الكلمه
بدايه عبد السلام اود ان اشير الى
اننا في هذه الغرفه التي يعقد فيها
المؤتمرات الصحفيه وتصدر عنها اخر
التحديثات تم وضع الطاوله كبيره الان بدلا
من المنبر الذي كان ياتي اليه المسؤول هنا
ويعلن على الحصيله على ما يبدو سيكون
امامنا مؤتمر صحفي هام للغايه بمشاركه
اكثر من مسؤول والى ذلك الحين الارقام لم
تتغير كثيرا عما اعلن عنه صباحا لكن
باجراء مسح بسيط على صفحه افاد على تويتر
نلاحظ بان عدد الهزات الارتداديه زاد خلال
الساعه الاخيره ساعه واحده فقط فيها اكثر
من عشر هزات ارتداديه ما يعني ان الرقم
المعلن عنه صباحا
1117 هزه سيزيد بكل تاكيد بالنسبه للحصيله
القتلى كما قلنا قارب 13 الف
الجرحى بات يقارب 63 الفا عبد السلام ايضا
بملاحظه بسيطه مقارنه الاعداد بين الليل
امس وصباح اليوم ومقارنه هذه الاعداد بين
عده ساعات رصدنا فيها هذه الحصيله خلال
يوم امس الارتفاع في الاعداد ياتي كبيرا
للاسف القتلى يرتفع بفارغ ثلاثه الاف قتيل
الجرحى يرتفع بفارق عشره الاف جريح هذه في
الحقيقه يعني ارقام ضخمه للغايه وفروقات
عاليه لكن حتى الان
مازال هناك احياء يخرجون من تحت الانقاذ
اخرهم فتاه بالغه من العمر 17 عاما خرجت
حيه بعد اكثر من 70 ساعه من الزلزال في
منطقه غازي عنتاب وهذا في الحقيقه
يعني بالضروره تكثيف اعمال الانقاذ
وانتشال العالقين من تحت الانقاض لعلهم
قبل ان يلتقطوا انفاسهم الاخيره هناك
معلومه اخرى صدرت من افات قليل تتعلق
بالاجلاء تم اجلاء اكثر من 28
الف شخص من تلك المناطق المنكوبه كيف يتم
هذا الاجلاء اما عبر استخدام الطرق
المفتوحه وذلك لان هنالك طرق متضرره تم
اغلاقها وطرق ثانيه يتم اغلاقها لتستخدم
فقط من قبل طواقم الانقاذ بحسب الاوامر
الصادره هنا من افاد يستخدم كذلك طائرات
جويه الرحلات شركه الخطوط الجويه التركيه
تعلن عن تسيير رحلات اكبر لنقل لهؤلاء
المتضررين وفي بعض المدن يتم النقل بحرا
باستخدام بعض السفن بالطبع العمليه ليست
سهله كما يبدو ولكن حتى الان اعداد من يتم
اجلائهم تتزايد مع
ازدياد اعداد المن يخرجونهم من من تحت
الانقاض لذلك هذا ما يسمح لبعض العائلات
التي تعرفت على مصير بقيه افرادها بمغادره
هذا المكان اف ايضا عبد السلام اعلنت عن
انتهاء اعمال انتشال العالقين تحت الانقاد
في شانلي اورفا هي المنطقه الثانيه بعد
منطقه كلس نحن نتحدث عن مدينه يقتلها اكثر
من مليونين نسمه هي كثافه سكانيه عاليه
مقارنه ببقيه هذه المدن كلس انتهت اولا
وكان ذات كثافه سكانيه منخفضه 150 الف
تقريبا لكننا الان نتحدث عن منطقه بعدد
سكان كبير الجهود الان تتجه نحو المدن
الاكثر تضررا سيتم نقل طواقم الانقاذ من
شانلي اورفا الى المناطق الثانيه من قبيل
غازي عنتاب وهاتاي هذا سيساعد في الحقيقه
بتسريع عمليات الانقاذ لننتقل الى المرحله
التي تليها وهي مرحله رفع الانقاض وهي
ايضا ليست
بالمرحله السهله بالنسبه لتطور اخر اعلن
عنه من افات كذلك الوصول للقرى والمناطق
النائيه بدا اسهل في هذه المرحله
في اليومين الاولين كان هنالك صعوبه شديده
في الوصول لتلك المناطق سوء الاحوال
الجويه انهيارات صخريه عدم القدره على فتح
الطرق هنا يتحدثون عن الوصول لتلك المناطق
هذا الامر ايجابي لكنه يؤشر بالضروره الى
ارتفاع الارقام في الساعات المقبله لاننا
سنشهد احصائيات وحصيله قادمه من تلك
المناطق
الجرحى والمصابون عبد السلام من من هم
اصاباتهم بالغه يتم نقلهم الى مدن ثانيه
من قبيل انقره واسطنبول باستخدام الطائرات
عبد السلام